bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat la commission
d' enquête sur le rôle des banques dans
l'évasion fiscale poursuit ses auditions
aujourd'hui elle entend le ministre en
charge du budget bernard cazeneuve
depuis la loi sur la régulation des
activités bancaires toutes les banques
sont tenues à une double obligation
rendre compte d'abord des activités de
toutes leurs filiales à l'étranger mais
aussi informer le ministère des finances
de tous mouvements financiers suspects
qu'elle découvre irait bien sûr il
s'agit d'engager sur la base de ces
déclarations des investigations pour
lutter contre la fraude fiscale
car l'évasion fiscale son coût est
évalué entre 30 et 50 milliards d'euros
pour la france
milla milliards d'euros pour les 27 pays
de l'union européenne
alors le gouvernement va aller encore
plus loin il préconise notamment la mise
en place d'un parc et financier et
l'aggravation des sanctions contre les
fraudes fraudeurs l'occasion pour la
commission des finances précisément d'en
savoir davantage sur ces mesures tout de
suite donc direction la salle médicis
pour l'audition du ministre en charge du
budget bernard cazeneuve très bonne
après midi à tous sur notre chaîne bien
mes chers collègues nous allons
poursuivre cette après midi de 10 sion
par celle de monsieur ministre bernard
cazeneuve
monsieur le
ni et éventuellement d'ailleurs deux de
ses conseillers
j'ai le ministre naudy sion enfin
déroulement d'une commission d'enquêté
vous le savez oblige évidemment à prêter
serment je vais donc recevoir votre
serment ce que je vais proposer
également dans la mesure où vous
conseillez interviendrait c'est que
ceux-ci également prêté serment s'il n'y
vois pas d'inconvénient
je vous demanderai donc alors de nous
donner votre nom votre qualité
tout de suite après l'énoncé du
cerf-volant monsieur le ministre
monsieur bernard cazeneuve battez-vous
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité levé la main droite et dit je
le jure je le jure je vous en remercie
pouvez-vous vous présenter avant que
basse alors qu'à direction générale des
finances publiques sous directeur du
contrôle fiscal
alors monsieur prêter ou serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité
voulez-vous levé la main droite et dit
je le jure je le jure je vous en
remercie makonda d'egypte chef de la
mission pilot stage au service du
contrôle fiscal
je le jure je vais quand même vous
redire le serment car sinon les formules
le respect des formes ne serait pas tout
à fait acquis alors monsieur prêté le
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité leva la main droite et dit je
le jure je le jure merci beaucoup et
enfin monsieur frédéric brio je suis
conseiller spécial est chargé de la
fiscalité ou cabinet monsieur bernard
cazeneuve
monsieur arrêtez vous au serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité
payer les a levé la main droite et dire
je le jure jugeant je vous en mets
cheminée je vous propose que nous
procédions comme nous le faisons depuis
le début de cette commission c'est à
dire par si vous le souhaitez un exposé
de 10 minutes sur ce que vous souhaitez
nous dire sur le thème de nos recherches
de notre enquête
après quoi je donnerai la parole
haéri poké notre rapporteur qui vous
posera les questions qu'ils souhaitent
et éventuellement mêmes j'en suis sûr
par la suite mes collègues animeront le
débat qui se terminera par les dernières
questions du rapporteur et
éventuellement toute précision que vous
jugeriez utile de rajouter ce ministre
vous donne la parole bien monsieur le
président monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
voudrais tout d'abord vous remercier
pour votre hospitalité votre invitation
je suis devant vous aujourd'hui dans le
cadre des travaux de cette commission
denquête à quelques heures de
l'ouverture des débats devant le
parlement sur la loi relative à la
fraude fiscale et la grande délinquance
financière et je suis très heureux de
pouvoir avoir cet échange de pouvoir
répondre à vos questions parce que je
sais la qualité du travail fait par
votre commission dont j'ai lu parfois le
compte rendu des auditions sur les
sujets les plus sensibles implication du
rapporteur de votre commission sur ces
sujets depuis longtemps les nombreuses
propositions qu'il a pu formuler sur de
multiples questions qui touchent à la
lutte contre la fraude fiscale en séance
et dans ses fonctions de rapporteur de
votre commission denquête et je me
réjouis de pouvoir sur ces propositions
et sur celles qui contiennent le projet
de loi pouvoir engager les changes avec
vous vous me donnez quelques minutes
pour introduire le sujet je vais donc
aller à l'essentiel de manière à ce que
nous puissions prendre le temps du débat
et de la réponse aux questions bien
légitime que voudraient me poser en
m'excusant par avance si je ne peux pas
répondre à un certain nombre de
questions qui ne relèvent pas de mon
coeur de compétence mais qui peuvent
relever de la compétence de
l'administration de bercy et si c'est le
cas je vous proposerai de répondre par
écrit dans les heures qui viennent aux
questions que vous aurez posé pour
lesquels un peu d' expertise technique
complémentaire sera nécessaire
et d'abord quelques chiffres qui
montrent l'équation du sujet entre 2011
et 2012
nous avons émis pour 2 milliards de
titres de recouvrement et de pénalités à
destination de contribuables auteurs de
fraude fiscale ces titres et pénalités
ses droits et pénalités sont passés de
16 18 milliards entre 2011 et 2012
sur ce montant global il y à peu près 6
milliards soit un gros tiers et qui
résulte d' actes de fraude fiscale très
significatif c'est dire l'importance de
l'enjeu de l'équation qui se présentent
à nous et l'intérêt que nous avons à
nous doter de moyens d'investigation de
contrôle et de recouvrement qui permet
dans un contexte de crise
particulièrement difficile pour les
finances publiques de faire en sorte que
ceux qui sont à contravention avec le
droit puisse à un moment donné se
trouver dans l'obligation de régulariser
leur situation car il n'y a aucune
raison que
l'effort de redressement des comptes
n'associe pas ce qui depuis longtemps
oublié d'exercer leur devoir de citoyen
de contribuables nous avons déjà pris
depuis quelques mois de nombreuses
dispositions dans le cadre de la loi de
finances rectificative pour 2012 et la
loi de finances initiale pour 2013
visant à renforcer les dispositifs de
lutte contre la fraude fiscale je
voudrais rappeler quelques-uns des
quelques unes des dispositions que nous
avons eu engagé et fait adopter
premièrement pour ce qui concerne les
particuliers pour des particuliers qui
ont déposé des avoirs sur des comptes
situés à l'étranger et qui ne serait pas
en situation de rétablir devant
l'administration fiscale la traçabilité
de ces fonds un prélèvement hauteur de
60 % des montants déposés sur ces
comptes pourrait intervenir ce qui
n'était pas le cas jusqu'à présent
nous avons également pour les
entreprises pris un certain nombre de
dispositions destinées notamment à mieux
lutter contre les transferts de
bénéfices vers des pays à fiscalité
avantageuse
vous savez que jusqu'à présent lorsque
il y avait un doute sur les raisons pour
lesquelles les transferts étaient
intervenus il appartenait à
l'administration fiscale d'établir la
preuve de ce transfert sur lequel les
interrogations avaient pu naître
désormais c'est au contribuable lui-même
et qu'il appartiendra d'indiquer les
raisons pour lesquelles il a été procédé
à ces transferts
lorsque l'administration à une
interrogation sur les raisons de ces
transferts de la même manière
de manière à éviter que il y ait des
transferts de bénéfices vers des pays à
fiscalité avantageuse et des déductions
de charges en france permettant une
double optimisation de la situation
fiscale d'un certain nombre
d'entreprises
il a été décidé de modifier la fiscalité
applicable aux intérêts d'emprunts
contractés par des entreprises de
manière à signer plus double phénomène
optimisation des bénéfices à l'étranger
et l'optimisation des charges en france
nous sommes allés beaucoup plus loin
encore dans le cadre de la loi bancaire
en obligeant les banques et leurs
filiales a déclaré l'ensemble de leurs
activités à l'étranger de façon
extrêmement détaillé de manière à ce que
nous puissions avoir une meilleure
expertise et une meilleure visibilité
sur ce qu'est l'activité des banques et
de leur filiale
et de la même manière les banques qui
constate des mouvements de fonds dont
l'origine peut être considérée comme
suspecte peuvent et doivent eux mêmes
doivent seulement mais c'est déjà une
obligation forte communiqué à trac fin
toutes informations relatives à ces
mouvements de fonds
par ailleurs nous avons décidé de
renforcer encore le dispositif existant
à la faveur de la loi qui sera présenté
devant le parlement à partir de demain
que s'agit-il de faire il s'agit d'abord
de renforcer les moyens de
l'administration fiscale et de la
justice en réarticulant le rôle de la
justice et de l'administration fiscale
de manière à faire en sorte que cette
articulation permettent une plus grande
efficience de la lutte contre la fraude
en prenant des dispositions que je veux
rappeler premier point lorsque des
contribuables indélicats ont utilisé le
recours à des sociétés écrans ou à des
comptes à l'étranger
les dispositifs mobilisés par la police
judiciaire d'enquêté fiscale pourront en
terme de garde à vue capacité
d'infiltration mobilisation aussi des
coûte
dans le respect bien entendu des règles
qui encadrent respect rigoureux des
règles qui enquêtent encadrant les
écoutes judiciaires
la police judiciaire enquête fiscale
pourra mobiliser ses moyens que jusqu'à
présent elle ne pouvait pas mobilisés de
la même manière nous avons décidé
d'inscrire dans la loi des dispositions
qui permettront à l'administration
fiscale dès lors qu'elle s'est vue
communiqué une liste de façon licite
c'est à dire par le truchement de la
justice dont l'origine elle même ne
l'est pas licite de pouvoir exploiter
totalement ses listes ce qui n'était pas
possible jusqu'à présent la cour de
cassation ayant dans le cadre d'affaires
dont les médias ont amplement rendu
compte
refuser que la totalité des éléments
communiqués à l'administration de façon
licite puissent être exploitées par elle
dès lors que la source n'était pas
illicite
ils ont pensé qu il était donc important
que dans le texte de loi des
dispositions permettent de ne plus être
confrontés à cette difficulté
par ailleurs nous avons décidé de
pouvoir recouvrer plus facilement les
sommes dues par les contribuables
auteurs de fraude fiscale dès lors
qu'ils ont été identifiés et que les
pénalités et autres amants de commence à
s'appliquer à eux
c'est ainsi qu'une personne morale qui
s'est livré à des actions notamment de
blanchiment de fraude fiscale
pour avoir la totalité de ses biens
saisis et dès lors qu'il s'agira de
saisir les biens d'un auteur de fraude
fiscale
il pourra être saisi jusqu'à l'assurance
vie lorsque nous sommes confrontés à des
cas de fraude fiscale de grande ampleur
je pensais ces quelques exemples pour
vous montrer que c'est un renforcement
considérable de l'arsenal juridique qui
présentait et puis il faut bien le
reconnaître une pénalisation jeu
politique plus répressive que ce qui
existait jusqu'à présent puisque les
amendes pouvant aller jusqu'à 10 2
millions d'euros et des peines
d'emprisonnement à 7 millions c'est en
parle et je voudrais maintenant dire
pour conclure quelques mots sur deux
sujets ce qui se passe au plan
international au plan européen
parce que tout ce que nous ferons plan
français n'aura que peu de portée si
nous ne sommes pas capables de créer les
conditions d'un arsenal d'instruments
d'action d'initiative de lutte contre la
fraude fiscale
au plan international et européen qui
soit vraiment très efficient c'est la
raison pour laquelle et le g8 qui vient
de se tenir en témoigne nous avons
décidé au plan européen au plan
international de mettre en place des
conventions automatique des échanges
d'informations et de faire en sorte que
ces conventions automatique des changes
d'information permettent entre
l'ensemble des pays et de l'union
européenne et au plan international
d'être garantie que chaque état pourra
obtenir de l'autre des informations
extrêmement précises concernant les
avoirs détenus à l'étranger par des
contribuables du ressort territorial du
pays demandeur c'est ce qui a été acté
au sein du g8 et c'est ce que nous
voulons mettre en oeuvre au sein de
l'union européenne
à la faveur de la renégociation des
directives épargné de la directive anti
blanchiment au 4 en faisant en sorte que
il y des conventions automatique des
chances d'information harmonisées entre
l'ensemble des pays de l'union
2 que l'union européenne puisse signer
avec des pays tiers de l'union
européenne des conventions de type fatca
3 qu'il y ait une liste européenne
d'état et de territoire non coopératif
parce que une manifestation par l'europe
une volonté à la matière sera toujours
plus forte que la détermination d'un
pays seuls de l'union européenne utile
de désir de se positionner en
avant-garde
enfin je voudrais après avoir dit
quelques mots sur ces aspects
internationaux et européens de façon
très rapide même s'il ya beaucoup de
sujets qui reste encore à travailler je
pense notamment à l'élaboration des
registres des trusts un sujet
considérable sur lequel on n'a pas été
aussi loin qu'on l'aurait souhaité dire
quelques mots sur la régularisation des
fraudeurs dans la tente de la loi ce que
je lis des choses extrêmement contrastée
comme si volontairement ou rouler sur
ces sujets entretenir la confusion où la
polémique
nous nous avons gouvernement une idée
très claire de ce que nous voulons faire
et je veux l'arrêt exprimé devant votre
commission sous prétexte que nous allons
durcir l'arsenal répressif et pénales
nous n'allons pas tomber dans ce travers
qui consisterait à dire aux fraudeurs
écoutez sous prétexte que nous allons
durcir et que par conséquent nous
pouvons pour mettre une cellule qui ne
sera pas de régularisation nous allons
attendre de vous attraper pour récupérer
les sommes que vous me devez ce serait
quand même absurde d'être dans une
approche exclusivement pénale alors que
le durcissement peut conduire d'ores et
déjà des contribuables à régulariser
leur situation
mais ce qui compte pour nous c'est
qu'ils paient leurs impôts et que ce
qu'ils doivent aux pays puisse être
acquittée dans un contexte de
redressement des comptes
mais cela ne peut pas se faire dans
n'importe quelles conditions cela doit
se faire dans des conditions de droit
commun par des conditions de 30
par ans et dans des conditions qui
permettent au parlement d'avoir à
connaître des conditions dans lesquelles
ces régularisations s'opère droit commun
ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que les contribuables qui
veulent se régulariser doivent pouvoir
le faire auprès des services de
l'administration qui existe depuis
longtemps dont c'est le métier sans que
une structure particulière soit créé
pour les accueillir il ya des structures
des services au sein de directions
générales science publique je pense
notamment à la direction nationale de
vérification des situations fiscales qui
savent parfaitement faire cela c'est
donc ces services qui sont des services
qui fonctionnent d'ores et déjà qu'ils
pourront accueillir ces contribuables et
le droit commun ça veut dire aussi que
les textes votés par le parlement et qui
définissent le niveau des peines
applicables de pouvoir être appliquées à
ces contribuables lorsqu'ils viennent se
mettre en conformité au droit
je veux rappeler un certain nombre
d'éléments sur ces poids ceux des
contribuables qui ne se régularise pas
mais sont attrapés au terme des enquêtes
se voient appliquer un niveau de
pénalité qui est 80%
il est donc normal que ceux qui viennent
devant l'administration fiscale de même
se voient appliquer des pénalités elles
aussi défini par le législateur moins
importantes que celles qui s'appliquent
à ceux qui sont pris en flagrant délit
en même temps c'est pas nalité qui
s'applique à ceux qui viennent se mettre
en conformité au droit devant
l'administration ne peuvent pas être
laissé dans le flou sans précision
donnant ainsi le sentiment que des
transactions s'opère dans la plus grande
opacité il faut qu ait des règles et que
ces règles reprennent ce que le
parlement a voté et que ces règles
s'appliquent à tous les contribuables
dans les mêmes conditions c'est-à-dire
qu'il y ait un barème que ce barème
pic dans les conditions identiques à des
contribuables venant se présenter devant
l'administration parce que le principe
d'égalité devant l'impôt peut être
appliquée c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai indiqué que non seulement le droit
commun signifier le passage devant les
structures direction générale des
finances publiques compétentes
l'application des barèmes votée par le
parlement précisé dans leurs modalités
d'application par une circulaire que je
prendrais et dont le parlement aura à
connaître annuellement
parce que je rendrai compte chaque année
devant le parlement des conditions dans
lesquelles tout cela s'est opérée
combien de dossiers
combien de personnes combien de fonds
récoltés
quelles conditions de traitement des
dossiers en toute transparence
voilà et bien entendu aucune remise sur
le montant des impôts ne sera fait de
manière à ce qu'il n'y ait pas la
moindre ambiguïté donc droit commun
transparence par le rendu qui sera fait
devant le parlement et la mise en place
de cette circulaire est enfin pas
d'anonymat que ceux qui viendront devant
l'administration ne viendront pas tester
l'eau en y mettant le bout du pied
non ils viendront eux mêmes sans le
truchement d'un conseil sans anonymat
ils présenteront leur situation fiscale
et barèmes leur seront appliquées
ils se mettront en conformité au droit
dans les conditions que je viens
d'indiquer voilà quel est l'esprit de ce
que nous voulons faire de manière à ce
que chacun soit invitée dans une période
encore une fois où il est important que
chaque cas acquittent ce qu'il doit au
pays que nous puissions le faire dans
des conditions qui soient transparentes
et irréprochable voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire concernant la manière dont
nous entendons travailler ce que
contient le texte de loi est maintenant
je me tiens à votre entière disposition
pour répondre à vos questions merci
monsieur ni ça je passais immédiatement
la parole à notre rapporteur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je repartirai de votre dernier
propos à propos de des retours de
repentis entre guillemets un quotidien
national faisait état ce week end d'un
chiffre de 5000 évadés entre guillemets
qui se seraient présentés à bercy qui
aurait pris contact avec vos services
pour justement régulariser leur
situation
est ce que vous confirmez infirmer ou
est ce que vous pourriez nous éclairer
sur ce point et et en cas de réponse
positive ce que j'imagine qu'ils aient
calé comment les choses se passent
thèmes et vous avez déjà abordé un peu
un peu le sujet la deuxième question
également précise concerne la liste des
états non-coopératifs ma connaissance
elle n'a pas encore été publié à la date
d'aujourd'hui par la france à ma
connaissance donc comment se fait il est
est ce que ce n'est pas dans ce cas-là
une une faiblesse une difficulté
supplémentaire dans l'appréhension de ce
difficile le sujet la troisième question
je vous avais fait référence au sommet
du g8 qui s'est tenu hier en irlande du
nord donc j'ai sous les yeux la
déclaration finale
cosigné par les huit chefs d'état j'ai
quand même le sentiment mais vous me
direz si vous partagez ce sentiment
qu'on est encore un peu trop dans la
déclaration d'intention on a des
recommandations les états devraient on
est sur le mode de la recommandation du
conseil de l'intention je pense pas je
n'ai pas le sentiment qu'il y est eu de
décisions actées précise engageant la
mise en oeuvre de procédures effectives
précise à partir d'aujourd'hui
alors est-ce qu'il s'agit d'un d'une
déclaration compromis c'est possible
puisqu'il y a quand même intérêt y
compris au sein de ces vies 8 et à des
intérêts divergents voire antagoniques
parfois par exemple est-ce que qu'elles
sont quels ont été les états les plus
réticents par rapport à la rédaction de
ce texte
je pense notamment à l'échec par rapport
à l'enregistrement des trusts qui n'a
pas été retenue
voilà est ce qu'il ya vraiment un front
uni au sein de l'union européenne
la question vaut premier européenne mais
également au sein de ce g8
au delà des intentions et une quatrième
question pour démarrer l'entretien nous
venons d'entendre à l'instant monsieur
monsieur michel aujean qui est un ancien
directeur d analyser les politiques
fiscales direction générale de la
fiscalité d'union que pour la commission
européenne et il nous a cité inca d'une
seule entreprise qui gagnaient entre
guillemets 5 2 6 milliards d'euros grâce
au régime des intérêts notionnels belge
vous connaissez cette particularité de
nos amis et voisins belges les intérêts
notionnels
avez vous une estimation du coût pour
nos finances publiques de ce régime
particulier des intérêts notionnels et
et du régime italien également qui
amènent un peu au même au même résultat
voilà une première série de quatre
question monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le président pour ces questions
et pour ce qui concerne l'impact de ce
dispositif d'intérêt national belge et
italien il s'agit là d'une question qui
a été évoqué plusieurs reprises dans vos
travaux qui implique pour nous des
éléments de retraitement assez complexe
qui d'ailleurs ne garantissent pas qu'on
puisse faire ce calcul est apportée
cette réponse de façon extrêmement
précise
les services sont en train de regarder
cela et je vous propose dans les
meilleurs délais de vous adresser une
réponse écrite sur ce point ça fait
partie des sujets qui appelle si l'on
veut avoir le niveau de précision que
l'on doit à une commission
une assemblée parlementaire un peu
d'investigation une méticulosité je
propose sauf à ce que les services est
avancée depuis sur ces sujets pointus de
revenir vers vous je m'y engage dans
quelques jours par une réponse écrite
qui pourrait d'ailleurs faire l'objet de
votre part de demandes complémentaires
auxquelles nous répondrons volontiers si
nous avons les éléments que vous mesurez
bien que je me dise que l'enjeu est
d'importance contenu et réglementant
cité l'enjeu est très important la
mesure est complexe et comme l'enjeu est
important la mesure ne peut pas se
permettre d'être aléatoire
je propose qu'on prenne le temps
d'apporter une réponse précise à cette
question qui bien entendu fait sens et
est un sujet de préoccupation autant
pour vous que les pour nous pour ce qui
concerne maintenant les 5000 noms et si
nous avons une idée précise du nombre de
personnes susceptibles de se présenter à
nous et du montant que nous sommes
susceptibles de récupérer de ces
personnes cela ne signifierait que nous
savons précisément qui fraudent et
combien chaque fraudeurs détient je vous
confirme que ce n'est pas le cas car si
c'était le cas sans que nous ayons à j
cela signifierait à une forme de
défaillance dans nos services qui n'est
pas la manière qu'ont nos services
d'agir lorsqu'ils savent je découvre
depuis quelques semaines que je suis à
tête de 7000 cette administration la
qualité de ceux qui se consacrent à 7 h
l'exigence qui est la leur dans la
poursuite de ceux qui fraudent et le
recouvrement des sommes qu'ils nous
doivent
et pour conséquent la question que vous
posez une question à laquelle on ne peut
répondre qu'année après année en
fonction de ce que l'on récupère en
raison des dispositifs qu'on a mobilisé
or comme nous sommes dans une nouvelle
étape législative que comme je vous
l'indiquais tout à l'heure nous
procédons à un renforcement des
sanctions susceptibles d'être appliquées
à ceux qui fraudent seul ou en bande
organisée qui soit personne morale ou
personne physique que d'autre part ce
projet de loi non seulement renforce les
peines mais renforce considérablement
les moyens alloués à l'administration de
la justice à travers la création du
parquet spécialisé
j'en ai pas parlé tout à l'heure mais
c'est un élément déterminant de la loi
ce parc est spécialisée qui va ré
articuler le rôle entre les années
juridiction régionale et le parquet
spécialisé en concurrence les uns par
rapport aux autres pour être sûr que
l'on puisse couvrir le plus largement le
territoire et d'assurer le traitement
d'un plus grand nombre de cas cette
nouvelle organisation constitue un
élément déterminant
portés par les dispositifs législatifs
donc nous serons au terme de la
mobilisation de tous à six et cinq mille
6 et plus et nous rendrons compte
annuellement c'est ce que j'ai indiqué
tout à l'heure au parlement du nombre de
cas des sommes prélevées des conditions
de traitement et des peines des
pénalités à mende appliqué à chaque cas
pour ce qui concerne la liste de tnc je
pense qu' il serait hautement efficaces
que nous puissions créer les conditions
compte tenu de la dynamique en cours d
évolution très importante en union
européenne au sein de l'union européenne
que nous puissions créer les conditions
pour que cette liste soit publié par
l'union elle-même ça aurait beaucoup
plus de force qu'une publication d'une
liste nationale
c'est ce à quoi nous travaillons et bien
entendu si nous n'y arrivons pas dans le
cadre des dispositions en cours et des
dialogues en cours au sein de l'union
européenne nous prendrons nos propres
responsabilités pour publier cette liste
en france dans les meilleurs délais
c'est à dire dans les semaines qui
viennent à la faveur de l'adoption de la
loi avec un principe simple qui est
qu'il ne suffit pas d'avoir une
convention d'échangé d'informations avec
la france pour le pas est sur la liste
convention d'échangé d'informations et
nécessaire mais cette convention
d'échangé d'informations doit conduire à
des échanges affectifs d'informations
entre les pays les y enseigner est ce
que un dispositif dans lequel nous et
nous signerions des conventions sans que
ces conventions ne souhaite appliquer la
convention servant d'alibi à ne plus
figurer faire figurer tel ou tel pays
sur la liste avec une effectivité une
opérationnalité très relative de ces
conventions
tout cela ne trompait personne n aurait
aucune efficients en termes de lutte
contre la fraude fiscale c'est donc non
seulement la signature de la convention
mais l'opérationnalité de la convention
elle même qui doit nous guider sur ce
point pour ce qui concerne j'ai vite
vous avez raison monsieur le rapporteur
des choses ont été faites mais il reste
beaucoup à faire
il reste beaucoup à faire pour quoi
parce que si la convention automatique
des changes d'information
au grâce notamment aux initiatives
prises par les états unis qui ont réussi
à travers la signature de ces
conventions de type fatca à créer un
autre équilibre au plan international si
tout cela a permis de faire avancer les
habitudes de changer la donne
on voit bien que sur les trusts sur les
registres sur les déclarations pays par
pays
les choses ne peuvent se faire qu'au
plan international et qu'il ya encore
des interrogations et des réticences qui
ont été exprimés d'ailleurs à l'occasion
du g8 ci a conduit le président de la
république française à dire que l'on
avait beaucoup progressé mais que l'on
n'avait pas pu aller aussi loin que la
france l'aurait souhaité donc l'idée ici
est bien de continuer à mener ce combat
en profitant de la dynamique à l'oeuvre
au sein de l'union européenne pour aller
au bout des choses aller au bout du
démantèlement des trusts au bout de la
transparence un grand pas a été franchi
mais je conviens avec vous monsieur le
rapporteur qui a encore beaucoup à faire
féministe en attendant de passer la
parole à mes collègues j'ai un titre
personnel deux questions une première
qui peut paraître un peu technique mais
qui ne l'est pas tant qui concerne aussi
la transparence des poursuites
un parquet spécialisé va être créé pour
autant lorsqu'on est en matière de
fraude fiscale je ne parle pas de
l'infraction de blanchiment de fraude
fiscale
pour autant lorsqu'on est en matière de
fraude fiscale il ne peut pas y avoir de
poursuites sont que l'administration et
auparavant pris l'initiative de saisir
massif à la commission des infractions
fiscales ce qui laisse penser et même
écrire à certains auteurs que ya un
petit manque de transparence parce qu en
quelque sorte je ma formule est forte
mais l'administration peut choisir ses
cibles ou ses victimes est ce que vous
n'avez pas l'intention ou est ce que
vous ne pensez pas qu'il est temps de
supprimer
l'intervention intermédiaire du visa
administratif par l'intermédiaire de de
la commission des infractions fiscales
ça c'est ma première question la
deuxième est plus général
on l'a entendu de nombreuses personnes
en particulier une qui était en jeu dont
je pense à une audition particulièrement
clair qui est une super levade qui ont
attiré notre attention qui était
d'ailleurs à ce point c'est soutenu sur
le fait qu' on parle quelquefois de
l'effet avant des causes et là on part
pas de l'harmonisation fiscale
on pense que si l'harmonisation fiscale
était beaucoup plus étendu on règlerait
beaucoup de problèmes dont ceux qui nous
agite aujourd'hui est ce que le
gouvernement a des actions en cours pour
inciter je me situe qu'au plan européen
si vous voulez bien pour simplifier ma
question pour inciter tous nos
partenaires européens parvenir à une
harmonisation fiscale acceptable dans un
délai bref ce qu'il ya des actions en
cours ou est ce qu'il y à des
initiatives prévues pour hâter cette
harmonisation fiscale qui me semble-t-il
assécherait beaucoup de problèmes
beaucoup de technique en matière
d'évasion fiscale ça ce sont les deux
questions je préfére merci beaucoup pour
ces deux questions je veux revenir si
vous me autorisé sans perturber la
méthode de la commission d' enquête sur
la question des trusts que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure pour apporter
juste quelques petits compléments
d'informations sur des sujets sur
lesquels je n'ai rien dit et qui mérite
d'être porté à la réflexion collective
d'abord pour ce qui concerne les trusts
c'est une notion qui n'existe pas en
droit français c'est une notion qui
existent essentiellement en droit anglo
saxon sous une forme juridique qui est
très utilisé dans les pays de droit
anglo saxon où son usage d'ailleurs
n'est pas nécessairement un usage
d'intermédiation d'opacité pour
accompagner des actions de fraude
fiscale il arrive que les trusts soit
utilisée de façon extrêmement positive à
des fins caritatives ça existe le g8
malgré
les difficultés qui sont posés en raison
du positionnement d'un certain nombre de
pays sur la publication des registres
est prévu quand même des plans d'actions
internationaux pour identifier les
propriétaires des trusts ce qui est un
premier pas qui est insuffisant au
regard des ambitions que nous pouvons
porter ensemble mais qui est un premier
pas qui mérite d'être soulevée on aurait
pu sans doute aller plus loin mais cette
première étape est une étape importante
dont il ne faut pas négliger les effets
je rappelle par ailleurs que sur le
sujet de la transparence des structures
opaques n'est à l'ordre ce sujet est à
l'ordre du jour de la communauté
internationale que depuis peu depuis le
g20 de washington en avril dernier qui a
pour la première fois posé la question
par conséquent nous avons avancé très
vite sur des sujets dont la maturité
politique et courte parce que la
question a été posée depuis peu de temps
et donc nous sommes nous la france
décidé si d être extrêmement offensif
sur ces sujets et de manière à ce que
nous puissions obtenir des résultats
pour ce qui concerne les deux questions
vous posez monsieur le président c'est à
dire la cif et l'harmonisation fiscale
nous pensons que ce qui compte c'est de
ne laisser aucun interstices aux
fraudeurs et de faire en sorte que
l'articulation entre l'administration
fiscale et la justice soient optimisées
de manière à ce que l'action conjuguée
de la justice et l'administration
fiscale fasse peser sur le fraudeur une
pression dissuasive et lorsque l'acte
est constaté une action répressive qui
permette de dissuader ceux qui voyant la
répression se déployer pour être tenté
de faire de même
pourquoi est-ce que je tiens beaucoup à
cette articulation et comment nous
procéder pour faire en sorte que cette
articulation soit plus efficiente
je tiens beaucoup à cette articulation
parce que le temps d'hadji d'action de
l'administration fiscale est un temps
court entre le moment où
l'administration fiscale constate la
fraude elle est armée pour le faire et
le moment où elle demande aux
contribuables devient vouloir payer les
sommes dues
il s'écoule moins de temps que lorsque
le temps judiciaire et mis en mouvement
et par conséquent nous devons avoir
cette rapidité d'intervention
parce que cette rapidité d'intervention
là elle est la garantie 1 que le
fraudeur n'aura pas le temps de prendre
le temps de nous faire oublier ce qu'il
nous doit important 2 que dès lors que
la fraude est constaté que le niveau des
amendes et pénalités qui est susceptible
d'être appliquée aux fraudeurs les on
peut appliquer rapidement le montant
maximal d'amendé de pénalité je veux
quand même signaler que le montant de
peine le plus important appliquée par
l'administration fiscale
au cours des dernières années était de
68 65 millions d'euros ce qui n'est
quand même pas rien on voit bien le
niveau de peine qui est susceptible
d'être appliquée aux fraudeurs par
l'administration fiscale
et quand on regarde la moyenne des
peines sous forme d'amendés de pénalité
c'est quand même très significative
donc on a intérêt à ce temps court et à
ce niveau de peine rapide et en même
temps dès lors que l'administration
fiscale constate qu'il faut aller devant
la justice il faut que nous soyons
garantie d'une fluidité du passage et
d'une transparence du passage de
l'administration face fiscale vers la
justice
c'est la raison pour laquelle concernant
le rôle et la composition de la
commission des infractions fiscales
je suis pour ma part très favorables à
ce qu'il soit rendu compte devant le
parlement dans des conditions peut-être
que la discussion parlementaire
permettra de préciser durdu de la
manière dont la commission des
infractions fiscales examine les
dossiers qui lui sont transmis et décide
ou non de les transmettre à la justice
je veux quand même dire que
l'administration fiscale transmet un
millier de dossiers par an et que la
commission des infractions fiscales
décide de ne pas donner suite à peu près
10% de ce volume global de dossiers
transmis ce qui signifie que
l'administration fiscale est quand même
extrêmement sévère
regarde ce que
après si parfois les magistrats de la
cour des comptes et du conseil d'état
qui sont membres de la commission des
infractions fiscales que je vous
comprends qu'il serait légitime de
rendre compte des raisons pour
lesquelles ce pourcentage de dossiers à
échapper à la transmission par la
commission des infractions fiscales au
juge judiciaire
tout à fait mimile saisine de la cif
mais au regard du nombre de contrôles
lacie fait très peu saisis et le
procureur henry qui l'assistent
quelquefois aux audiences du tribunal de
commerce
peut-être témoin de choses ce qui pose
problème au niveau fiscal et s'il serait
certainement intéressant qui lui aussi
puis déclenché les poursuites
monsieur le président deux remarques
d'abord pour ce qui concerne les
chiffres précis le nombre de dossiers
transmis l'an dernier à la cif 1126 le
nombre de dossiers transmis par la cif
au juge 987 donc les 10% soit à peu près
là beaucoup dé dossiers qui ont été
contrôlés et non transmis à la cif sont
malgré tout des dossiers qui ont fait
l'objet d'une sanction à caractère pénal
sous forme d'amendés de pénalité parfois
extrêmement lourdes par l'administration
fiscale et je veux rappeler d'ailleurs
que la peine en forme d'amande ou de
pénalités applicables aux fraudeurs par
l'administration fiscale à au sens
juridique du terme
la portée de la sanction pénale c'est la
raison pour laquelle je trouve très
absurde tout ce dialogue qui se nouent
sur peut-on garantir l'impunité pénale
offre deux hommes étaient là sont le
fraudeur qui viennent devant
l'administration fiscale et qui se
voient appliquer une peine et une amende
est un fraudeur qui fait l'objet d'une
sanction pénale puisque l'amande et la
peine en valeur et porté de la sanction
pénale la question n'est pas de savoir
s'il échappe à la sanction pénale ou pas
lasser question est de savoir s'ils
échappent à la procédure judiciaire ou
pas mais on va jaillir il ya une
gradation
toujours entre la faute commise et la
sanction appliquée cette gradation
d'ailleurs est en droit une garantie du
respect des libertés publiques des
principes qui régissent le droit en
france et de la qualité du
fonctionnement de la justice nous
aurions une embolisation de la justice
si nous cherchons à échapper à ce
principe de proportion et si nous
cherchons systématiquement à pénaliser
donc il faut que nous ayons bien à
l'esprit que les miss dossiers qui sont
transmis à la ciw ne signifie pas qu'il
n'ya que 1000 dossiers qu'ils fassent
l'objet d'une sanction pénale parce qu'à
tout l'amour et la mort parfois en
termes d'amante qui ont valeur encore
une fois de peine au sens pénal du terme
ces dossiers sont parfois très
lourdement sanctionné mille dossiers
quand même pas résiduelles parce que
tous les contrôles ne décèle pas de la
fraude parmi ceux qui décèdent de la
fraude
beaucoup font l'objet des sanctions que
j'indiquais il y en a quand même 1000
qui passe à travers la cif 10% sont
rejetés et ensuite le juge poursuit je
dois dire que parmi le millier de
dossiers qui fait l'objet de poursuites
pénales
le nombre de ceux qui aboutissent à des
peines privation de liberté sont peu
nombreux ce qui signifie qu' il n'y a
pas nécessairement de corrélation entre
la nature de la procédure et la sévérité
de la peine plancher
donc ce qui compte pour nous c'est qu'il
y ait une administration pénales qu'ils
puissent agir vite qu'ils puissent
pénaliser financièrement au bon niveau
c'est à dire sévèrement et que tout ce
qui relève de la compétence de la
justice ne lui échappe pas que les juges
aient les moyens de travailler de façon
indépendante en étant armée d'où la
création du parc et les spécialisées et
que les conditions dans lesquelles
fonctionnent la commission des
infractions fiscales soient
transparentes donc pour ce qui concerne
la composition comme pour ce qui
concerne les conditions de restitution
au parlement
des critères à partir desquels la cif
agit et le rendu de l'activité de la cif
est possible devant le parlement si les
parlementaires le souhaitent et en tous
les cas dans ma responsabilité et demi
son budget je ferai toujours en sorte
que cela soit possible
par ailleurs j'ajoute qu'une autorité
judiciaire c'est l'article l101 du livre
des procédures fiscales qui soupçonne
une fraude fiscale doit immédiatement
saisir l'administration fiscale de
manière à ce que celle ci puisse
diligenter ce qui doit l'être pour
mettre fin à cette contravention au
droit donc on n'est pas sans lien entre
l'administration fiscale et le pouvoir
judiciaire j'ajoute que depuis l'arrêt
talmont de la cour de cassation le juge
judiciaire a la possibilité de se saisir
et d'instruire de toutes infractions
relevant du blanchiment de fraude
fiscale
sans que l'administration fiscale elle
même ne tue à agir préalablement donc on
est aujourd'hui dans une autre
articulations justice administration
fiscale c'est la raison pour laquelle le
projet de loi plutôt que d'opposer
l'action de la justice à celle de
l'administration fiscale l'articulent
lui donne de la force de la puissance et
cette force et cette puissance est
articulations sont à mon avis beaucoup
plus dissuasives pour le contrevenant
que ne le serait une opposition entre ce
que l'administration fiscale en planche
est ce que le juge pourrait lui-même
déclenché pour ce qui concerne
l'harmonisation fiscale question
essentielle sur laquelle nous sommes
mobilisés dans le cadre de réflexion
conduit notamment par le commissaire
chez meta dans le cadre notamment de ce
qui se passe autour de l'impôt sur les
sociétés accis etc
si beaucoup je vais passer la parole
maintenant à notre collègue nathalie
goulet voulez vous monsieur le ministre
nous regroupions les questions avec
celle de philippe dominati
oui oui monsieur le ministre merci pour
pour ses propos vous savez combien le
sénat est la première commission avait
déjà travaillé sur ces sujets et voir
arriver un texte que nous allons voter
bientôt et quand même une très bonne
nouvelle
moi je voudrais vous poser deux
questions l'une sur sur l'état
actionnaire
parce que l' agence pourrait
participation de l'état regroupe à peu
près cent trente quatre milliards
d'euros dans des sociétés multiples et
variées et nous avons auditionné il ya
quinze jours le responsable de l'agencé
des participations de l'état et il
semblerait qu'à certains égards l'état
soit parfois un peu schizophrène c'est à
dire quand on est il est actionnaire
d'un côté et en même temps il a il a un
autre rôle en matière fiscale donc nous
avions proposé lors de la précédente
commission denquête que l' agence pour
les participations de l'état puisse
établir un rapport au parlement sur la
situation et des sociétés dont l'état
était actionnaire
comment voyez vous l'évolution de cette
proposition notamment par l'utilisation
dans les sociétés dans lesquelles l'état
est actionnaire de schémas
d'optimisation fiscale ça me semble
important qu'on ait que le parlement
soit bien informé sur l'état actionnaire
en dehors du jaune budgétaires que nous
avons mais aussi sur la fiscalité des
entreprises dont l'état est actionnaire
la deuxième question est directement lié
à l'audition que nous venons d'avoir et
rejoint les propositions qui avaient été
faites notamment dans là dans le projet
de loi sur la modernisation de
l'économie
il s'agit de créer un pôle universitaire
de fiscalité internationale notamment
propre et semblablement sous l'égide de
recherche fiscale merci de recherche sur
la fiscalité parce que dans l'ensemble
des auditions que nous avons eues et par
mille
les écueils se trouvent les difficultés
de cerner et d'appréhender la fraude
notamment pour les prix de transfert
mais on en avait parlé la dernière fois
lorsque nous avons évoqué l'efficacité
des conventions fiscales et le problème
de la formation des personnels qui vont
avoir à être compétent pour appréhender
la fraude fiscale est extrêmement
important
d'autant que cette fraude
s'internationalise et sait donc comment
vous voyez-vous et est-ce que vous
pourrez soutenir ce projet de création
d'un centre scientifique sur la
fiscalité internationale qui qui serait
à paris ou en province
je crois que cet aspect de formation de
nos agents dans cette guerre de l'eau
bue et du blindage est extrêmement
importante
philippe dominati le seul ministre
j'aimerais profiter de votre audition
pour avoir votre sentiment
votre sentiment d'abord sur le rôle des
banques en france puisque c'est un
secteur qui occupe tous les
gouvernements depuis 2008 en tout cas
depuis la crise financière
on a déjà eu l'occasion de faire un
certain nombre d'auditions
mais je voudrais connaître votre
sentiment d'une part sur le rôle des
banques nationales qui sont très souvent
ont des liens assez étroits avec l'état
c'est tout à fait naturel
j'ai eu la loi de régularisation et quel
est le rôle des banques nationales elle
est votre appréciation du secteur
bancaire national dans l'éventuelle
l'évasion des capitaux
deuxièmement le rôle des banques
étrangères sur le territoire national
puisqu'il ya un certain nombre
d'exemples nous avons eu au cours de la
dernière commission denquête un certain
nombre d'exemples particulier mais il
semblerait qu'il y ait des éléments
nouveaux qui ont eu lieu donc
pouvez-vous nous informer sur le
sentiment de votre administration
vis-à-vis du rôle des banques
le titre de la commission c'est des
acteurs financiers ou six alors à côté
des banques est ce qu'il ya des secteurs
financiers dans notre pays qui sont
particulièrement je dirais pas citoyens
pour verser les impôts qui sont dus à
l'état
est-ce que vous ciblez par certains
secteurs financiers particuliers enfin
vous avez donné le sentiment de
sur votre administration sur
l'efficacité de votre administration le
mot efficacité dans le titre de la
commission est ce que vous estimez que
la france dispose d'un dispositif et
d'une administration relativement
performante pour lutter contre l'évasion
fiscale ça avait été l'une des
préoccupations de notre dernière
commission je pense qu'il ya une
dynamique qui a été établi depuis 2008
est-ce que vous vous sentez dans la
continuité de ces dynamiques où vous
avez trouvé des aspects ou des grands
manques qui vous permettrait d'être en
rupture politique et éventuellement
d'aller dans d'autres propositions par
rapport à ce qui s'est fait depuis la
crise financière de 2008
enfin j'ai noté que lui hier ou
avant-hier ou g8 le président de la
république qui est offensif dans ce
domaine s'est fait reprocher par
certains chefs d'état je dirais
l'existence d'un de nos propres paradis
fiscaux est ce que cela entraîne pour
vous une une action particulière puisque
alors est-ce à tort health a raison ça
franchement là ou si vous avez peut-être
une appréciation mais j'ai cru
comprendre qu'un certain nombre de chefs
d'état nous devons nous demander de
revoir la situation d'andorre de monaco
est-ce que ça va déclencher de votre
part une action particulière voilà
qu'elle s'était les sentiments que je
voulais avoir de votre part sur ce sujet
si vous n'y voyez pas d'inconvénient je
vous propose également deux groupes et
la question de notre collègue chiron
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
ça va ça va dans le sens de notre
collègue dominati est ce que vos
services vont faire une action
relativement forte à partir des
connaissances qu'ils vont avoir du
milieu bancaire dans dans les mois qui
viennent puisqu'il doit faire un certain
nombre de déclarations
est-ce que
cette ses relations entre
l'administration fiscale et enoh et les
banques françaises au moins bons vont
permettre de te regarder devoir de
connaître comment les banques françaises
ont pu accompagner
je dirais alors on va parler
d'optimisation qui peuvent se
transformer en évasion quand même se
transformer en fraude parce qu'on sait
que tout ça c'est lié bon dans les dents
les dans les états qui ne naquit ne puis
n'applique pas une véritable je dirais
transparence il voir comment nos propres
banques ont pu accompagner ces dérives
je dirais et quels moyens elles ont
utilisé dans ces pays là sachant que on
nous a dit quelque chose de récemment ac
qui nous ont interrogés c'est que on
peut pas demander certains états on se
met en infraction si on demande à son à
sa propre filiale comment on gère les
comptes
les citoyens français qui sont allés
ceux qui ont qui sont allés transférer
un certain nombre de deux
de somme dans ces pays notamment la
suisse ont ce quelqu'un qui est qui
travaille pour la banque française
x à genève ne peux pas divulguer la
façon dont il travaille pour un citoyen
français qui seraient qui auraient des
comptes en suisse
donc est ce que c'est la même chose au
luxembourg est ce que c'est la même
chose en irlande
c'est un peu les questions que je pose
parce que bon les banques françaises
vont bien de devoir un moment donné
explique et leur fonctionnement et leur
accompagnement
mais je pars dans le champ des questions
et est large aussi je vous propose de
2,10 répondre maintenant puis après nous
terminerons cette audition par
différentes questions qui restent en
suspens de notre rapporteur
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
j'ai commencé par les questions de
madame boulet pour ce qui concerne tout
d'abord la situation des entreprises
publiques au regard des entreprises
privées et pour nous la loi fiscale est
la même pour toutes les entreprises
qu'elles soient publiques ou privées je
dirais même que et il y a un devoir
supplémentaire des entreprises publiques
de se conformer au droit
l'état est garant de la bonne
application du droit en france avec les
juges
il s'est quand même paradoxal que des
entreprises au capital desquelles se
trouve l'état soit moins vertueuses
alors que l'état comme actionnaire a la
possibilité d'exercer un regard
extrêmement précis sur les conditions
dans lesquelles ces entreprises
fonctionnent que les entreprises privées
donc la loi fiscale est la même pour
toutes les entreprises que l'état soit
leurs actionnaires ou qu'il s'agisse
d'entreprises intégralement détenue par
des actionnaires privés
ça signifie quoi ça signifie d'une part
que la loi fiscale va naturellement être
appliquée avec la même sévérité à
l'encontre des entreprises publiques que
les autres et d'autre part que ces
entreprises bénéficient comme les autres
d'un certain nombre du bénéfice d'un
certain nombre de règles je pense
notamment au secret fiscal
mais je vais plus loin encore en nous
disant que
ces entreprises doivent être parce que
l'état se trouve à leur capital
particulièrement vertueuse et nous
sommes là aussi dans une situation
nouvelle avec l'évolution des esprits et
des exigences exprimées non seulement
par les organisations non
gouvernementales mais par un certain
nombre d'états même dont la france au
sein des instances internationales et
européennes
je pense notamment à tout ce qui
concerne les leur porting pays par pays
nous avait vus dans le lobe bancaire ce
principe a été inscrit il a été inscrit
sous condition que l'union européenne
accepte le principe nous sommes très
favorables à ce que l'on puisse
progressivement avancer vers leurs ports
thing pays par pays
mais en même temps nous sommes très
soucieux de faire en sorte que la france
ne soit pas seule à le faire parce que
si la france est seule à le faire
là où les autres ont décidé de s'en
dispenser nous allons exploser nos
entreprises sous prétexte que nous
voudrions être à la gang à l'avant-garde
a des conséquences qui pourraient être
préjudiciables
donc il faut toujours être à l'avant
garde il faut faire en sorte que sur ces
sujets des choses progressent mais nous
pouvons pas non plus exposer nos seuls
intérêts là où les autres nous regardent
et nous regarderait le faire
tranquillement sans bouger sans accepter
de se conformer aux mêmes règles que
celles que nous impose rien nous mêmes
donc il ya des sujets sur lesquels on ne
peut progresser que dès lors qu'on est
dans un cadre européen et international
et notre rôle à nous il est double faire
en sorte que dans le cadre européenne
cadre international et les lignes
bougent et faire tout ce que nous
pouvons faire de nous mêmes sans
attendre les autres pour que les lignes
bougent
à condition que ce que nous décidons de
faire seul ne soit pas de nature à
porter atteinte aux intérêts de notre
économie et de nos entreprises
vous me posez ensuite la question de
savoir ce que nous comptons faire pour
nos propres paradis fiscaux c'est
monsieur dominati qui me posent cette
question et une différence entre
des paradis fiscaux qui sont à proximité
de la france et les paradis fiscaux qui
sont partie intégrante d'état ou liés à
eux par des liens qui sont des liens que
je qualifierais de liens ombilicaux
monaco et andorre sont des territoires
et des états souverains
ce n'est pas le cas d'un certain nombre
de paradis fiscaux qui dépend de la
couronne britannique sont pas du tout
dans la même relation avec la couronne
britannique que nous nous sommes avec
ces territoires
et pourtant nous pensons qu'il faut agir
sur tous les paradis fiscaux
c'est la raison pour laquelle il y
aurait de la force du sens à ce qu'ils
aient une liste de tnc européenne et que
cette clis témoigne de la volonté de
l'europe d'éradiquer partout les paradis
fiscaux qui dépendent d'elles et l'ayant
fait l orée de la force pour faire en
sorte qu'au plan international les
choses puissent évoluer et bouger donc
la position de la france est très clair
nous souhaitons durcir la liste
la convention d'échangé d'informations
ne suffit pas il faut qu'elle soit
effective et nous pensons qu'il lui
aurait vraiment du sens et de la force à
faire cela au plan européen le préciser
que les relations d'ailleurs fiscale
entre la france et monaco sont depuis
63 garante de l'absence d' optimisation
donc avant même que je ne sois n'est les
choses avaient déjà progressé et et
monaco a été évaluée de manière plutôt
satisfaisante par le forum mondial
récemment en raison des progrès qui ont
été accomplis
et il faut là aussi être extrêmement
précis dans les terminologies parce
qu'il ya un certain nombre de paradis
fiscaux qui mérite ce qualificatif mais
lorsque l'on emploie ce terme de paradis
fiscaux pour andorre et monaco on est
dans la simplification en réalité compte
tenu des évolutions que je viens
d'indiquer là et nous avons encore
récemment signé des conventions avec
andorre pour progresser dans la
transparence
compte tenu de ce qui s'est passé on ne
peut plus qualifier aujourd'hui monaco
et andorre de paradis fiscaux au même
sens que le sont d'autres paradis
fiscaux
comment oui voilà non mais de notre
point de vue d'accord mais je précise
quelle est la nature des relations
juridiques qui ont été noués avec ces
états qui sont des états souverains
comment nous avons traité quelles sont
les évolutions conventionnel qui sont
intervenus et qui au regard de notre
propre situation ne les placent pas en
comparaison avec d'autres miliciens si
je peux me permettre
quel est le statut de ces deux
territoires évoqué regard du gafi
notamment et sa liste des territoires
non coopératifs
alors je vais vous laisser répondre aux
gars du gafi parce que moi j'ai pas la
réponse technique là je n'ai pas un je
veux pas vous raconter de chose qui soit
pas juste je n'ai pas cette réponse le
graphiste un critère le les critères qui
utilisent le gafi sont des critères de
blanchiment sont pas des critères à
proprement fiscaux
donc sur ce sur ce point là précisément
moi je ne peux pas apporter cette
réponse autre que ce que je sais que que
je viens de vous dire c'est à dire
encore une fois les critères à partir
desquels le gafi se positionne sont des
critères de blanchiment sont pas des
critères paradis fiscaux mais je peux si
vous voulez
regardez cette question et vous
l'apporté ultérieurement je ne mets pas
là alors
ensuite vous vous posez la question des
banques de la finance de l'efficacité de
l'administration pour ce qui concerne
les banques et la finance des choses ont
beaucoup évolué au cours des derniers
mois vous avez voté une loi
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs qui
change considérablement la relation de
l'état des organes de contrôle de
l'administration fiscale aux banques sur
le sujet qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
avant le vote de la loi bancaire il n'y
avait pas d'obligation pour les banques
de déclarer à trac fin les mouvement
suspect ayant transité par les banques
et l'administration de bercy n'avait pas
la possibilité de connaître de ses
mouvements
nous sommes très vigilants à ce que
aucun de ces mouvements n'échappe à
l'obligation de signalisation et il y a
un gros travail qui est fait par tracts
fin de ce point de vue là dans le cadre
des règles qui régissent le
fonctionnement de tracts faim et qui
témoigne d'une efficacité qui monte en
puissance
la loi bancaire par ailleurs oblige
l'ensemble des filiales des banques à
déclarer leurs activités à l'étranger et
par ailleurs nous complétons les
dispositions de la loi bancaire par des
dispositions contenues dans la loi dont
vous aurez à débat dans les semaines qui
viennent qui condamne toute action
commise par des conseils ou des banques
en termes d'optimisation fiscale qui
conduirait les banques ou les conseils à
franchir la ligne qui sépare
l'optimisation fiscale de la fraude
fiscale donc les banques elles mêmes
dans les conseils qu'elle dispense à
leurs clients seront appelés à davantage
de vigilance demain que par le passé
donc tous ces éléments là sont des
éléments qui change considérablement la
rolls de l'administration fiscale face
aux bancs qui conduisent à un ensemble
d'obligations des banques à l'égard de
l'administration
et qui sont des obligations qui jusqu'à
présent n'existait pas et pour ce qui
concerne l'efficacité de
l'administration
il est une caractéristique de
l'administration de bercy quelles que
soient les critiques qu'on peut lui
apporter qui m'arrive de lire véhiculée
par votre presse c'est que cette
administration et une administration qui
a au sens de l'intérêt général et qui a
un sens du droit qui l'a conduit parfois
à l'appliquer de façon extrêmement
rigoureuse juste
j'entends plus de critiques sur l'excès
de rigueur et de contrôle globalement
que sur l'excès de l'accise même s'il
arrive que sur certains sujets on pointe
telles ou telles interrogations
donc je moi je considère je ne lis pas
parce que je suis à la tête de la
migration est une expression efficace
performante exigeante
il ya un au sens de l'intérêt général
qui est pétri de la culture de l'impôt
au sens le plus noble du terme c'est à
dire la manifestation par les citoyens à
travers leur contribution de leur désir
de contribuer au fonctionnement des
services publics et d'assurer un haut
niveau de protection sociale
et tout cela se fait avec une culture de
l'administration de bercy
l'administration fiscale qui est une
culture de l'exigence est hautement
professionnel j'ai répondu en même temps
vos questions je crois monsieur fillon a
promis je vous remercie d'abord de vous
prêter un dépassement de l'horaire je
vous propose de transiger quelque chose
sur ce point et nous laisser dix minutes
qui permettront peut-être de répondre
d'obtenir les réponses aux dernières
questions de notre rapporteur bien ce
ministre à votre place à ses manières
nous avons auditionné
monsieur condamin gerbier donc vous avez
entendu parler d'eux des propos qu'il a
pu tenir devant la commission est ce que
ces déclarations vous hante amené à
prendre des dispositions au niveau de
votre ministère par rapport aux
déclarations faites de l'existence d'une
liste de personnes étaient politiques de
premier plan qui aurait détiendrait donc
des comptes et compte en suisse
donc est-ce que ça vous amène à prendre
des initiatives
suite à cela par ailleurs la presse
bruisse beaucoup ces temps-ci de l'éco
divers ou sur le sujet et on peut pas
s'en étonner il faut même je crois sont
félicités il se dit notamment que
l'entourage du président de la
république dès le mois de décembre et
été informé de la situation exacte de
votre prédécesseur dans ses fonctions
est ce que vous savez si votre
prédécesseur a pu avoir un contact avec
quiconque au ministère de l'économie et
des finances sur ce sujet et est ce que
vous avez prévu est ce que vous
approuvez les conditions dans lesquelles
les échanges d'informations avec la
suisse a été conduit puisqu'il est s'est
avérée quand même que des questions
restaient est restée en suspens est par
ailleurs pouvez vous nous indiquer si on
a pris soin de consulter traque fin pour
vérifier l'existence de signalements
portant sur l'existence de ces comptes
de votre prédécesseur et et cette
précaution at elle également été prises
pour des ministres actuellement en
exercice
ensuite j'aimerais revenir sur l'
enquête sur l'x du mois de du mois
d'avril
est-ce que vous pouvez nous indiquer si
vous constatez un afflux de déclarations
on a évoqué les retours de repentis
entre guillemets ces derniers temps est
ce qu'il y aurait un lien est ce que et
quelles dispositions avez vous prises
pour répondre fiscalement à cette
éventuelle situation et pourriez vous
nous préciser s'il vous plaît la nature
et les enjeux de ces déclarations
tardives
enfin avoir avoir gagnaire question est
ce que pourrait nous indiquer le montant
des redressements fiscaux à pardonner
mans impressionnant rapporté vous pouvez
préciser cette dernière question pour je
suis sûr d'avoir bien comprise alors à
propos de charles x noël dont vous
pouvez vous nous indiquer si vous
constatez un afflux de déclarations
d'avoirs à l'étranger depuis la
publication de cette enquête et quelles
dispositions
vous avez pu prendre pour répondre
fiscalement cette éventuelle situation
est donc nous préciser en même temps
la nature et les enjeux de ces
déclarations tardives ensuite indiqué
également le montant des redressements
fiscaux appliqué aux contribuables dit à
fort enjeu aux personnes sensibles ainsi
que l'évolution des transactions
conclues avec ces deux catégories de
contribuables enfin une dernière
question pour l'avenir peut-être il ya
je crois en dans les tuyaux un projet de
réforme de la dgfip
enfin des réformes en profondeur pour
garantir l'absolu indépendance de cette
direction est ce que vous pouvez dire où
nous en sommes exactement de cette
réforme
merci il est évident entre une mini ce
que vous pouvez prendre les dix minutes
merci beaucoup monsieur le président je
vais commencer par la première question
qui est relative aux déclarations de
monsieur condamin gerbier devant votre
commission mais je crois savoir qu'il
n'a pas fait ses déclarations simplement
devant votre commission première fois
ici par la fête d'ailleurs je crois j'ai
invité ce matin monsieur condamin
gerbier à se rendre au 139 rue de bercy
de manière à bien vouloir communiquer
cette liste si monsieur condamin gerbier
à une liste qu il la communique et nous
sommes dans un état de droit
nous ne sommes pas dans un état de
délation nous sommes dans un état de
droit où le droit dabo a passé lorsque
l'infraction est commise
nous ne sommes pas par conséquent dans
un état de rumeurs on peut jeter en
pâture la réputation de tel ou tel sans
preuve
parce qu'on a décidé de se faire une
réputation une table il ya pas eu de
contact le ministre j'ai demandé
monsieur condé majeur bien de bien
vouloir déposer cette liste à bercy je
les fais publiquement c'est
susceptible d'être retrouvées sur
internet et en même temps il faut que je
le fasse dans le respect scrupuleux du
droit parce que il n'a pas échappé à
votre sagacité monsieur le sénateur que
nous sommes dans un régime de séparation
des pouvoirs que monsieur condamin
gerbier a je crois été auditionnés par
un juge et que j'ai cru comprendre
travers des éléments de presse qu'il
doit l'être de nouveau et par conséquent
nous devons tout faire pour que les
initiatives prises par bercy s'il doit y
en avoir
respecte rigoureusement les prérogatives
de la justice dont nous n'avons pas à
entraver les enquêtes et par ailleurs il
faut aussi que nous puissions sur ces
sujets dès lors que nous avons les
éléments war enquêter moi je souhaite
les avoirs s'avère ce n'est pas moi qui
les détient que c'est monsieur qu'on
damas quand je dis je souhaite les avoir
moi je n'ai pas à les connaître mais
l'administration bercy doit pouvoir en
disposer
donc j'invite ce monsieur sylla des
listes avec des preuves à les
communiquer à bercy et l'administration
compétente de bercy procédera à
l'ensemble des investigations qui relève
de ses compétences de manière à pouvoir
faire son travail conformément aux
règles de droit qui régissent le
fonctionnement de l'administration
lorsqu'elle à connaître éléments de
fraude fiscale mais on ne peut pas
reprocher à notre administration de ne
pas être détentrice éléments conduit a
pas transmis et qu'elle souhaiterait
obtenir de la part de ceux qui
détiennent ces éléments donc c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui le bercy ne dispose
d'aucune information corroborant ces
déclarations mais monsieur condamin
gerbier a été invité par mois ce matin à
venir cela dure depuis quelques jours à
venir transmettre cette liste à
l'administration de bercy de manière à
ce que l'administration de bercy
compétentes puisse procéder aux
investigations qui relève de ses
prérogatives conformément au droit
je considère que sur ces sujets là la
plus grande rigueur doit s'appliquer
l'état de droit encore une fois n'est ni
un état de délation ni un état de
rumeurs s'il ya des éléments des preuves
doivent être
communiquer à l'administration
compétente et l'administration
compétente procédera je vis en gach
l'année lé mans devant votre commission
à toutes les investigations qui doivent
être conduites ya eu réponse monsieur
condamin gerbier pour l'instant la
connaissance il ne s'est pas présenté
devant les services mais s'il l'avait
fait je n'aurais pas en connaître car
les services lorsqu'ils disposent
d'éléments de ce type font normalement
leur travail en toute indépendance et
sans recevoir de ma part d'instruction
parce que c'est aussi un élément auquel
je tiens et auxquels je dois me
conformer et je me conforme
rigoureusement
c'est ainsi que fonctionne bien
l'administration lorsque elle fait son
travail dans le respect rigoureux de la
règle de droit
ce que monsieur condamin gerbier comment
dirais je dispose mesures de protection
particulières vous savez qu'il a fait
état d'un climat particulier autour de
sa personne noire de menaces est ce que
des mesures de protection éventuel
aurait été prise mais pour le libre le
libérer un peu de se comprendre monsieur
leur apporte ce facile j'allais vous
répondre cela la situation de monsieur
le plein de ses jeux manière dont
l'administration française au sens large
du terme à traiter lequel monsieur fâché
ni montre lorsque la protection une
personne est nécessaire pour assurer le
bon déroulement des enquêtes sensibles
nous prenons toutes dispositions pour
que cela soit le cas
donc monsieur condamin gerbier peut
transmettre ces éléments et je le lui ai
demandé à l'administration fiscale
et s'ils se sont menacés en raison des
éléments dont il dispose il sera bien
entendu à l'instar de monsieur phal
ciani pour être protégé le cas cette
demande sera prise en compte
voilà ce que je peux vous dire mais
je ne voudrais pas qu'on reproche à
l'administration fiscale qui demande à
ce qu'on lui transmette des éléments
avec beaucoup d'insistance qu'elle ne
les ai pas ce qu'on a mangé reviennent
nous les communiquer je lui ai indiqué
ce matin qu'elle est l'adresse et je
peux lui indiquer aussi qu'elle est
l'étagé le bureau ce n'est pas le mien
bureau de fonctionnaires qui de façon
tout à fait professionnel font ce
travail avec méticulosité absolue il
peut être garantie du haut niveau de
professionnalisme qui présidera
al'expertise de cette liste par les
services de bercy
l'interrogé ensuite sur les demandes
d'échangé d'informations qu'elle il a
été procédé dans le cadre de la sphère
dit cahuzac
vous le savez mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs un bilan annuel des échanges
d'information dans le cadre de notre
réseau conventionnel et transmis au
parlement à l'occasion de la
présentation de la loi de finances
initiale sous la forme d'une annexe
jaune au projet de loi de finances cette
annexe comprend des données chiffrées
qui répondent précisément à votre
demande concernant en général les
conventions d'échangé d'informations et
nous actualisons par écrit année après
année de documents concernant la demande
adressée à la suisse comme toutes
informations couvertes par le secret
professionnel ou fiscal je m'engage à ce
que tous les éléments qui vous sont
communicables en votre qualité de
rapporteur de la commission dans quelle
puisse nous est transmis ça va pouvoir
de contrôle sur pièces et sur place
j'ai déjà et parfois pris les devants
pour que ce contrôle puisse exercer dans
des conditions de transparence absolue
je vous confirme ici devant la
commission denquête que si vous
souhaitez exercer ce pouvoir de contrôle
sur pièces et sur place la tâche vous
sera grandement faciliter l'information
sur le sujet que vous m'indiquer
l'information judiciaire est en cours
elle nous permettra de dire dans quelle
mesure
la réponse de l'administration fiscale
suisse a pu donner de la situation de
jérôme cahuzac
une image erronée ou non est par
ailleurs les auditions parlementaires en
cours ont déjà permis à pierre moscovici
au directeur général finances publiques
de rappeler que les questions que
l'administration fiscale a adressée aux
autorités suisses étaient et plus large
possible aussi bien dans leur objet que
dans la période et dans l'espace
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire sur ce
sujet et sur tracts un monsieur le
ministre les les vérifications pour être
traction trac fin par rapport aux
informations évoquées je peux vous
répondre sur ce sujet de façon générale
je vous confirme que traquent faé la
dgfip échanges efficacement les
informations dont il dispose et sur le
cas particulier de monsieur cahuzac jeu
si je répondais à cette question c'est
le sénateur j'enfreindrais un principe
qui s'impose à moi qui suis du secret
fiscal
alors je comprends que il soit dans la
nature de l'exercice de me pousser à
cette faute mais je ne la connaîtraient
pas parce que la ministre doit
s'appliquer à lui même
les règles que vous élaborez vous même
qui sont des règles fondamentales qui
garantissent y compris la protection du
contribuable dans le contradictoire
donc moi je peux évoquer toutes des
questions devant vous à l'exception de
celles que par le vote de la loi
on m'avait interdit d'évoquer devant la
représentation nationale donc je ne peux
pas répondre à cette question sans
enfreindre une règle que vous avez vous
même élaboré je vous demande de bien
vouloir m'en excuser mais je vous ferai
plaisir en répondant à cette question
mais je me mettrai en défaut devant vous
en le faisant en enfreignant les règles
de droit que vous avez vous même élaboré
c'est la difficulté de l'exercice auquel
le ministre du budget est confronté
parce que très souvent j'entends dire
mais on a écrit au ministre du budget
sur tel sujet sur telle succession sur
telle affaire fiscale ne répond pas mais
je ne peux pas répondre
le prof du ministre du budget c'est
lorsque il c'est parce qu'il sait ce que
d'autres ne savent pas il peut pas
parler et que d'état gens qui ne savent
pas par là à leur guise mais en revanche
monsieur le rapporteur est un engagement
je prends devant vous c'est que si vous
voulez la réponse à cette question votre
pouvoir de contrôle sur pièces et sur
place peut vous permettre de l'obtenir
et je fais toujours tout absolument tout
pour faciliter l'exercice par le
parlementaire du contrôle sur pièces et
sur place donc vous pouvez avoir la
réponse à cette question par les
pouvoirs qui nous sont conférés
mais je ne peux pas vous les donnez moi
même devant vous en raison de
l'obligation que vous m'avez fait par la
loi de me conformer rigoureusement
secret fiscal
un point très clair mais question ne
portait pas sur la situation
particulière d'un contribuable mais sur
le fonctionnement de l'organisme tracfin
sur le fonctionnement de l'organisme
traque fin ce sénateur je vous confirme
que les changes réguliers entre traque
philadephie permet de d'optimiser de
renforcer de conforter l'efficacité du
fonctionnement de l'administration de
bercy sur ces sujets
monsieur le ministre monsieur nous vous
remercions voilà pour l'audition de
bernard cazeneuve le ministre en charge
du budget vous pourrez l'abreuvoir
évidemment à tout instant sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée à tous sur notre
chaîne